[Musique]
ce traité a contraint son journal pour
les longues ailes j'espère qu'elles
seront sociaux tels voyages grand
portail et benzema sont couchés des
petites caméras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le petit écho de la forêt
ces intrus vrai c'est vrai il y à toutes
les informations à chaque nouvelle
édition on n'a jamais de dissection ça
vous le découvrirez dans l'homme qui
découlent de l'offre
à voyons la page des sports ont un grand
championnat de course à pied tous cas la
tortue favorite
home est très intéressant voyant sur qui
vais-je pariez vous le choix est délicat
n'est ce pas cher téléphone moi je mise
sur ip tasca avait été l'année dernière
qu'autre chose simple coup de sang pas
rien surtout ce qu emma sur vip et moi
sur tosca bourriche lellouche
surveillait l'autre et mot de tout ce
qu'a dit le chronomètre
1h03 du ceinture s'ils gagnent deux
sentiers possible mais zimpfer parcours
à 7 minutes 9 des yeux
je n'ai pas dit mon dernier mot
de son côté mademoiselle de la cigogne
s'occuper de zips lelièvre cinq minutes
6/10 bravo évident que les red eagle il
est là pour moi dans ce cas la tension
rien ne sert de courir on cherche il
faut partir à point si on m'avait déjà
dit c'est l'année dernière serait droit
de tourner mais non mademoiselle bon on
reprend l'entraînement aller où les que
valent-elles il le grand jour du
championnat arrive à un bon moment le
bon dieu est très vite cher téléphone
j'ai pris la tête de la course
vandal un dj a fait le plus grand raid
est plus la peine de vous préciser je
suis sûr de remporter la course pour
vous pouvez bien allongé à bâtir et
l'otan je verrais bien une petite sieste
il vous bat e
je croise et recroise zip est en train
de dormir mais nul et si réveille toi
en plus du zyban dormant mais tu ne peux
pas rond fait comme tout le monde de ce
type il ne faut pas que je perde la
course est allé de quoi auriculaire
laisse-moi zippé en paix cette cour ne
la gagnerai quand vous voudrez et tosca
cher téléphone continué sa course
lentement mais sûrement
[Musique]
savez vous où est passé notre chèr vie
petite reine
je les oublie tout à l'heure qu'est ce
que tu veux dire je les laisser sur
place et miga ou quoi j'en ai bien
apprécions les supporters de zips shirt
et les femmes partir à sa recherche
et quand ils le trouvaient endormi sous
les églantiers mais en phase il peut
vous rêvez gayet et n'aurait non tu t'es
un dormi panatta concurrents continuent
à courir
pas d'affolement faire doubler le zerg
ne peut pas courir mais elle peut gagner
impossible d'offrir le plus rapide mais
enfin si paul biya lui sert de courir il
faut partir à point
et justement que le vrai dire j'ai pu
faire tous les fans des baraques commune
sujet
everell fly y ait gagné des billets doux
malheureux tu as perdu shut up bobby des
biens 3 secondes que tosca a franchi la
ligne d'arrivée il a encore perdu cette
fois ci alors là bravo tu en feras tu es
la plus forte
je dois leur colère et comment es tu
fais c'est tout simple ce n'est jamais
oublier le conseil de ma grand mère
qu'elle vient de donner des tags envers
attend que je me souvienne elle me
disait ah oui c'est ça rien ne sert de
courir il faut partir à 3 et wii ce
pauvre type a encore perdu la course
contre la tortue pourtant il a toutes
les qualités pour faire un grand
champion magie d'un grand défaut il a
trop confiance en lui et pépé en tout
cas je vous dis à bientôt pour une
nouvelle édition du petit écho de la
forêt